in this session I'm going to be telling
you a bit about what's coming in Python
3.5 you probably aware that every 18
months or so we come out with a new
update to Python Python 3.5 is coming in
just a couple of months and so I want to
run through a few of the new things that
are going to be in it compared to three
four
some of them are really exciting new
features some of them are gotchas that
you need to be aware of and all of them
are important in one way or another
because this is such a short session and
there's so many things in here I have
left a number of things out so my aim is
to have enough time for questions at the
end that people like Brett whose feature
I have left out of this talk and asking
pointed question and get me to talk
about his contribution it's a Python 35
but I'm going to run through the ones
that I've picked as being of most
interest to the PI data community and
certainly the ones that are going to be
the most significant gotchas so I'm
going to start with one of the fun ones
unpacking this is pep 4 for 8 if you
want to look up more details and there's
quite a detailed pep on what this does
this is the unpacking syntax so if
you're familiar with Python then you
will have seen code like this where you
can have a sequence of some values and
if you assign it to comma separated
names than that unpacks it and so X is
going to get the first element Y the
second element Zed the last one recent
versions of Python will let you add an
asterisk in there which will collect
items if you have more than three so in
this case because we have five items
three of them are ending up in the last
value and you can do this anywhere
throughout the left-hand side of an
assignment to do to do this unpacking
and partial unpacking what this pep is
added to python 3 5 is the ability to do
it on the right-hand side of an
assignment as well my clicker has died
that did not last long
excellent what we've added is the
ability to do it on the right-hand side
of an assignment which means we're
before if you wanted to take multiple
values so you could always do the
assignment without the asterisk and that
will give you a couple of three elements
in this case that would give you a
topple of like we see down here integer
integer list
but if you want to make it a couple of
all five elements flattened out again
you can now unpack it which will give
you the value of W and unpacks so we're
actually taking a sequence and unpacking
it into the topple that were assigning
doing that on the right-hand side of an
assignment is new and in fact you can do
it in the middle wherever you like and
you can do it multiple times on the
right hand side so you can ask to risk
multiple elements to expand all of them
out and that will give you a nice thing
like that I have some nice 4 examples of
where you might use that you can also do
it with dictionaries so if you have
three dictionaries which is quite common
if you have dictionary arguments to a
function and you want to merge them
together this is one way you can do it
you make a copy of the dictionary update
update which will replace certain keys
with values but in 3/5 we have a new way
to do it which is to use star star
unpacking and you can now do this
straight into a dictionary and it has
exactly the same behavior as the first
one so it's a nice little abbreviation
it's something that people tried to do
because it seems obvious and now it in
Python 3 5 it's going to work and so you
can do this with function calls as well
if you want to specify arguments into a
function call from a sequence you've
always been out of star args star star
args but if you had two sequences you
want to pass in the functions you had to
concatenate them and then pass it as a
single item single star uggs the new
syntax you can just use multiple star
Uggs
this is the generalization so if you
have multiple multiple lists that are
going to be parameter values you can
star and star them separately and it's
effectively the same as concatenated
them and passing them as one argument
you can do the same thing with
dictionaries with star star uggs though
there is one gotcha with this which I
will come back to on the next page so
this is the new syntax where might you
use this where is this going to be
useful compared to what you've
previously done first up so you may use
it somewhere like this if you want to
find the minimum value in across two
lists and possibly even a constant or
multiple constants this syntax will now
work this is going
expand out both lists of values and find
the minimum value across all of them
previously you'd either be calling men
multiple times and nesting them or
concatenating into one sequence to find
the minimum with generalized unpacking
you can have a nicer syntax that will
let you get the result with less typing
let's say you have two sets of
properties that you want to overlay so
you have maybe some system-wide settings
and you want to apply user settings on
top of that into some function call you
can use the star star expansion
unpacking to get that you'll notice here
I haven't written the obvious way which
is now in red and crossed out this is
one of the gotchas and it's actually for
consistency rather than inconsistency if
you define a dictionary literal you can
specify the same key multiple times and
it will work the results are undefined
but it will work if you try and pass a
named argument to a function twice it
will complain and error out straight
away which means that you can't have the
same key keyword argument passed in in
the second syntax because you won't get
any odd behavior you'll simply get an
error because you've specified a name
parameter twice but expanding them into
the one dictionary and then passing that
will give the usual take a dictionary
update it replace any values with
matching keys and then pass all of those
in as parameters and you can use this
for conversions as well this is a
trivial example taking a topple turning
it into a list by saying I want a list
and I'm going to unpack the topple into
it so each value becomes a value in the
list but this is more interesting for
cases like this where you want to unpack
multiple sequences into a list and maybe
add some constant values in there as
well and so this compared to the
equivalent syntax which might involve
casting it's definitely involving
concatenation it might involve extend it
might involve loops definitely involves
literals this is considerably neater
it's going to work with any sort of
sequence it doesn't require values to
actually be a list and it's going to
give you the result that it reads like
it should so these are just nice little
syntactic features they
that seemed like they should work and
now in Python 35 they do for a move on
does anyone have any short quick
questions about this yes so in some
cases this may be more efficient in
other cases that may not there
especially when calling a function that
may or may not be more efficient than
calling min multiple times or
concatenated and then doing it there's
no sort of general answer to that it is
all in unless one of the other core
developers in the room has a specific
answer for whether it's actually more
efficient but the general answer is try
it and measure yes yes so if you have a
specific keyword argument that you want
to pass in the second example and either
you want to override possible user
settings or you want it to be overridden
by the other settings you would specify
that inside the dictionary so inside the
curly braces you can specify a regular
key in value either before between or
after the unpacking and unpacking always
proceeds from left to right inside a
dictionary so if you put it first it
will be overridden by either of the
following two dictionaries if you put it
last it will override any value with the
same key in those dictionaries okay next
one one in pet 465 we added a new
operator to Python 35 for matrix
multiplication so to prove the value of
this I have a quick challenge here for
you I'm gonna pop some code up on the
screen I want you to read it and when
you recognize whose theorem it is I want
you to put your hand up ready yep there
it is when you recognize whose theorem
that is put your hand up Oh
very good very good but would you have
recognized it quicker if it had been
written like that there's a really big
difference in readability between
function calls and operators which is
why we like in fix operators they're
much easier to read there's less
unnecessary parentheses there's less
white spaces less typing even with
highlighting to identify functions and
modules it's just generally shorter
easier to pause so here's another
example if you recognize this put your
hand up I'm not going to give you that
long but here is the example after we've
introduced the matrix multiplication
operator does anyone recognize it now
one person does excellent thanks for
coming Jake this I have no idea what
this equation means or what it does but
once you take out all those function
calls and replace it with a matrix
multiplication operator it becomes
easier to read it's easier to compare to
where else it may be written down if you
have this in the textbook you can
compare that far easier and you'll fire
less likely to make mistakes because
there's less parenthesis there slow the
addition to Python 3 5 is the Matt mole
operator Python does not actually use
this operator anywhere it's simply made
available in the hope is that libraries
like numpy are going to take advantage
of this by implementing the the
operators for the implementers in the
room these are the definitions the
symbol looks like an ad and that's going
to forward through to either the dunder
Matt mole are Matt mole or I'm Matt mal
implementation so you're numpy matrices
have gained a new operator but in fact
any library can use this operator for
any purpose just as any operator can be
overridden and some people are not going
to be so thrilled about that but others
are very excited to have one more binary
operator that they can use in Python 3 5
any questions yes decorators in number
so decorators because of the paths of
state when you encounter a decorator
there's no ambiguity in the a decorator
can't follow an identifier with that
beak without
with a line continuation a decorator can
follow and identify that is known to be
a decorator which can't be a binary
operator otherwise the @ symbol can own
like must follow some identifiers and so
it can't be a decorator so there's no
actual ambiguity there syntactically
it's clear assuming a well-written Pazza
some parsers may have trouble and they
also have bugs so it is unlikely to be
more efficient to use an operator than
writing it out as a function because the
implementation is effectively identical
there may be some optimizations you get
from using a function simply because you
can specify more context you can say
this matrix can be mutated in place or
this one can't with a nut with a binary
operator that's not always so clear but
it will come down to a library
implementation the library may make it
more efficient to use a function that
specifies like in place matrix
multiplication in some context where you
can't use the the @ equals augmented
assignment but that is going to be a
case for each library and in case by
case that makes use of this operator I
in theory you could use this for
first-class email addresses are you
coming to this prince so so you won't be
seeing first-class email addresses
anytime soon
but as soon as James gets some free time
I'm sure those will happen
okay nice quick one which I nearly
overlooked because this went into Python
three five a long time ago through Pep
four eight five and about two and a half
thousand emails on Python ideas when you
have two floating-point numbers
comparing them directly with equals
equals is a bad idea
we know this if you've calculated
results with floating-point numbers even
if they look the same chances are
they're going to compare differently and
so we come up with all of these helper
functions or tolerances equations to
avoid that and now Python 3/5 has it in
the math module so from math you can
import is close and make a simple call
and it's going to tell you are these
numbers close to control what close
means because but that has different
meanings in different places there's
some extra parameters here so absolute
tolerance is one of the options the
value that you pass for absolute
tolerance effectively gives us the ABS Y
minus X less than tolerance
comparison so that is shown quite there
because it's the simple one that we
normally use and now you can have that
directly from is close abs talk what was
decided in all of the discussion is that
a relative tolerance is more useful so
that's the default and the way a
relative tolerance works is based on how
large the numbers are the tolerance is
going to adjust so in this case I'm
using a relative tolerance of roughly
one percent which means if I compare 1
million and 1 million and one they're
treated as close and if you think about
it if you were given a choice between a
million dollars and a million and one
dollars it's close enough you can
largely ignore the difference but with
the same relative tolerance and much
smaller numbers we're now not close
anymore because 10 and 11 is a more
significant difference and if you go
down 1 and 2 are significantly different
the relative tolerance can be the same
and it will say no you're not close
anymore the larger number is the further
away it can be while still being treated
as close the default parameters in the
first case passes a relative tolerance
of I think 1 by 10 to the negative 7
so it does scale with value size and it
means you have about seven decimal
places of equivalence to say yes these
two numbers are close anyway anyone have
a question on is close yes
and I'm using integers yeah integers
work as well and they are I don't recall
if they convert it to floating-point I
suspect they are good point I got sick
of writing 0 integers I think our up
cast by the algorithm to be to actually
be floating point or at least some part
of the comparison is going to use the
floating-point tolerance to account for
that james yes the way to do that is
let's chat about that afterwards
okay this is a gotcha this is probably
the biggest gotcha
you're running out of quarter of
questions I'm just gonna stop letting
you ask pep for seven nine this is a
gotcha this is actually something that
could be considered a bug in all earlier
versions of Python that is being fixed
for it's actually being fixed for three
seven its you're able to get the
functionality in three five there'll be
a message in three six but three seven
you'll get this full behavior so this is
a chance to be prepared early and run
all of your tests through with the
functionality I'm about to show but the
problem is that we often or some of us
will we use functions that may throw
stop iteration occasionally you'll want
to search a sequence for some value and
you can do that using next and a
generator and then the first value that
matches is going to be returned and if
it doesn't find anything that throws
stopped iteration which means you can
call that function and handle stop
iteration and go off we didn't find any
if you apply this to a number of inputs
and put it in a list comprehension as
soon as we find one that does not find
an element it's going to throw stop
iteration this is where the gutter comes
in if instead I pass it to list so
instead of a list comprehension it's a
generator passed into lists what happens
when we don't find an element we
actually truncate the result so you
don't get an exception you just get a
shorter result because the stop
iteration has bubbled out and someone
has recognized that as oh we've stopped
iterating and so the list stops this is
a gotcha because the actual problem here
is that we didn't find an element that's
an an error that should be thrown out at
least in this case we expect it to be
thrown out it's not supposed to truncate
a comprehension
it's supposed to be bubbled out and be
caught and handled by our program code
so the way this is going to change and
the way you can enable that when we
advance
shifting that code across to the left
the future for 3.5 and 3.6 to get this
behavior is from future import generator
stop what this will change is in the
first case it doesn't actually change
anything you'll get stop iterations
still in the latter case now when the
stop iteration escapes from that
generator it's going to be caught and
it's turned into a runtime error so
you'll still get an exception in this
case this is a gotcha
I'm not holding this up as a beautiful
new feature this is letting you know
your code has a problem and you need to
resolve it a reason this may come up
depending on when you got into doing
generators in Python you may think that
raising a stop iteration is a great way
to get out of the generator early but
really this is where the problem comes
in because wall that will currently stop
iterating over the generator early in
most cases the right way to get out of a
generator early is actually to return
and by doing that it will it will jump
out of the generator correctly stop
iteration will be raised and handled but
that raised stop iteration within the
generator quite often comes from deeper
in and it's been decided for 3/5 that
that should be considered an error so
that may be something that shows up so
that from import statement from future
statement on the previous slide is going
to become the default behavior in 3.7
3.5 you can enable it now for your tests
run all of your code through tests with
that future enabled if you use a lot of
generators and you'll find these
problems sooner and be able to have a
much smoother port up to newer versions
of Python that was down in depressing
burdens anyone have any questions yeah
it won't be back ported to any earlier
versions that I'm aware of if you asked
really nicely someone might do it but
the earliest it would go back is 3/4 and
I don't expect that to be of any
significant value no bread shaking his
head it's not going to 3/4 so no
this one gets to peps so you know it's
Gordo's ideal type annotations are now
part of python 3 5 but what does this
really mean for your code so the idea
here is we've had parameter annotations
and function annotations in Python 3 and
never really agreed on what they should
be used for so there's been general
guidance on how to use them what and and
otherwise freedom on what to use them
for
for Python 35 the rule has been set down
annotations are for type hints so
parameter annotations tell the people
reading those type hints what types
should be passed in the function return
annotation tells people what is going to
come back out of that function that's
basically being laid down as the rule
now and so that is the major change for
3/5 does this mean that you should go
out and add type hints to all of your
code not does this mean you should take
your company style guide and write in
their add type annotations to all of
your code no these don't have any
runtime impact they're still annotations
unless someone actually reads them and
acts on them nothing will happen nothing
will change your code still runs exactly
the same and even if the types don't
match nothing happens at all the point
of this and in fact the point of
formalizing it for Python 3 5 is to
allow tools to build around these
historically you could define tools that
say these are type hints and we're going
to do analysis and give you results to
say these types don't match these ones
do but by formalizing it and saying
these are what annotations mean it gives
tools more of a chance to say ok we're
going to interpret the annotations like
this and actually build up around that
but until we have those tools we don't
know the best way to use these yet we
don't know which functions need
annotations which one should not have
them and so unless you're working on one
of these tools these are probably not of
a huge amount of interest for you unless
you're using them for other stuff in
which case at some point you may be
incompatible with these tools James
people really want this nobody uses my
PI and - would you be willing to give a
talk up high data Seattle 2017 if there
is a pep where we remove this nonsense
completely direct quote I will happily
talk about that as someone who works on
an integrated environment and does a lot
of Python code analysis I am really
looking forward to these being
standardized and being able to flow some
of this information through the
development environment I think this
will be of great value for developers
but there's still a question over how
best to use them and where they should
appear so until those are resolved we're
still in experimentation phase with
these a lot has been said on other peps
other talks
Guido gave a keynote on this at PyCon I
don't want to get too in-depth on what
it all means but this is something
that's new for three-five but it's not
something to adopt and start making few
jisub yet yes so that is that is still
an open question the official answer
seems to be yes it will make use of the
class hierarchy though in some cases you
don't want to make use of the class
hierarchy directly you want to be able
to use other sources of information
another question up the back or is that
the same one
so currently not yet and this is where
we need the tools to build up around it
this is where we need a data frame aware
linting tool that will recognize some
particular type with annotations these
are not necessarily how the annotations
will look it's possible to use any
arbitrary class it's possible to use
arbitrary strings but until we have
tools that are actually using these and
processing them we don't have the full
understanding of how it will look and
how it should be written so eventually
there may be a standard tool that people
reach for that will validate data frame
definitions but right now we don't have
that and so if this is an area that you
work in as far as code analysis this is
something for you to be interested in
and experimenting with for everyone else
this is a mild warning to not dive in
and start writing types everywhere
because it's not going to buy you
anything just yet I'm running short on
time so let's move on Pet 192 this
entire topic may be a surprise for a lot
of people because it's changing
something that was only added in Python
3 4 which is the async i/o library so in
Python 3.4 we gained async i/o which
gave which gave us suspended all
functions we've always had suspender for
functions in the form of iterators or
generators and now we've extended that
with a cio library to be a more event
based system so if you if you're
familiar with async await in c-sharp or
what's proposed for C++ or Java Script
it's effectively identical to how that
behaves you have a function that can
suspend at some point and be resumed
later when an external task is complete
the syntax in Python 3 4 is yield from 4
that we are reusing generators directly
to be able to suspend and resume a
function what this change for Python 3 5
gives us is a new syntax to define a
resumable function you now put async at
the front of def you have a sink def and
that makes the function resumable
whether or not you use the new keyword
for suspending the function which is now
await so this is effectively aim
relatively minor name change in the
syntax that brings us into line with the
way a lot of other languages are
implementing this exact behavior what it
also brings is some ways to implement
operations that are otherwise impossible
with straight generators because if you
want to get so if you implement a for
function like this it's going to do two
things it's going to call it err on the
arrow iterable you give it and then
repeatedly call next if you get a
knitter iterable asynchronously and
await that you would get code like this
where we'll suspend while we're getting
the iterable
but then synchronously step to each next
element what we really want is some code
that's like this in a lot of cases where
the first step may suspend because maybe
we've gone to query a database server
and each step through each element may
also suspend if we need to re query the
server whatever it happens to be and so
the syntax to get this behavior is now a
sink for there's not necessarily any
await in here in this case we're getting
an asynchronous iterable as opposed to
getting an iterable asynchronously or
just a straight iterable similarly with
context managers you can await a context
manager which will give you an object
and then we'll synchronous the enter
synchronously exit on the way in and out
of the block alternatively you can use
async width which will get the context
manager synchronously unless you have an
await in there as well but then it will
await on entry and a wait on exit which
means your suspender will function can
now suspend on the way out of a whiff
block this may be something like a
database transaction that's being
automatically committed on the way out
of a whiff block allowing your function
to suspend while it does that network
work and resume whenever it's complete
and meanwhile your main process thread
can be doing other work it is very much
looking like I'm going to be submitting
a full talk on async await because
everyone does it to the next PyCon so I
don't want to go too in depth into how
it all works right now but does any
have any questions about the syntax
change from yield from two async/await
okay now I get to the topic where I
contributed a considerable amount if you
use Python on Windows you're probably
familiar with this guy which is the
Installer on Windows it's a familiar
look we've had it for a large number of
versions now for Python 35 it's had a
facelift we have a new look installer
and on top of that the entire internals
have been redone
so we actually have a more configurable
installation of Python it's more
flexible it has a trooper user
installation that does not require admin
privileges anymore and it has a secure
all users installation that is no longer
a major security hole where any user on
your machine can change the packages
that your administrator is running every
time they use Python there's a lot more
command-line options than they used to
be so for automatic deployments there
are more options and if you download the
web installer initially from the Python
page you're downloading less than a
megabyte you get to make all of these
selections and then will download just
the files that you need and will in fact
let you go further for those embedding
and extending Python you can choose to
download debugging symbols and debug
binaries through the through the
installer as well a big part of this
change is also the move to a new
compiler Python 3.4 was built with the C
compiler that is part of Visual Studio
2010 and older versions from even older
compilers than that Python 3.5 is going
to be built with the C compiler from
Visual Studio 2015 which means that we
have among other things we have a
forwards compatible C runtime but we
also have breaking changes because we've
gone three major versions without
updating three major versions of the C
compiler and so features have been
deprecated and removed in that time
which means a number of extensions are
going to break we're currently in the
end of the beta period for three five
and coming into uh C one of the things
we really need at this point is trying
to build extensions with three five
finding out what doesn't work reporting
it to the pack
maybe submitting poor requests to fix
build issues which are large the minor
renames of functions but otherwise we
have a more secure runtime we have a
better compiler it will produce faster
code and it's more interoperable with
other system components and other
applications you may want to use it with
okay before I move on yeah yep so no
well possibly
no no just generally no it's a bug in so
the question is will it set the path
correctly when you install Python the
answer is no and the bug is in Windows
so that at this stage cannot and will
not be fixed because fixing that would
be such a major backwards compatibility
issue it would also become a hijack
vector to be able to do what we need to
do with the command line there the
recommendation for running Python from
the command line in PowerShell or
command prompt is to use the py launcher
and just type py - the version number
that you want to use putting Python on
the path you'll notice on that first
slide that it's unselected by default
which is something I insisted on because
it causes more trouble than it's worth I
am standing hard-and-fast against a lot
of people who want it to be on by
default but it's not going to happen
because it does not work reliably and it
will cause more trouble to encourage it
than otherwise you should be using the
py launcher and not typing patent alexey
the so some there have been a few tests
of some packages generated by siphon
it's not been done thoroughly to my
knowledge yes very little except that
hopefully the Anaconda team will be able
to have a clean like a they'll have an
easier time getting Python out of the
Installer and into their own package
that's not a question that's my
one-minute warning okay so I have one
more thing to talk about which is for
those who embed Python in their
applications for a long time it's been
really hard to distribute an application
that uses Python because there's been no
easy way to say I want Python in my
application and not interfere with
whatever the users installed so at the
moment we have an experimental bundle
that's coming out with Python 35 it's
known as the embedded zip effectively
it's a zip file that has these files in
it that's a complete listing and it
comes with the DLLs the idea is you can
drop this into your application
directory if you load the dll's directly
then you can use those if you call out
to the executable scripts then you can
use those the standard library is in a
zip file it's cut down slightly the
entire bundle is six to eight Meg it's
not real big it's considerably smaller
than Python and it deliberately does not
interfere with any other installations
on that machine so if he uses installed
Python 3 5 and you've bundled it with
your app your app gets your version it's
not going to conflict with what the user
has installed previous versions can't do
that so this is one of the improvements
for python 3 5 it's still experimental
we're still looking for you solve it and
actual experience with it whether we
need to make changes to how this works
but that is there and if this and if
bundling applications for Windows is
something that you do I would love it if
you tried it out and provided any
feedback on the issue tracker
so Python 3.5 is coming mid-september
we have RC releases coming out there is
fourth beta coming out tomorrow which I
have to go home and build now you can
get the free releases from that first
website python.org download pre releases
the full list of what's new because I
had to leave some things out of this
session is on the docs page you can
navigate to that make sure you're in the
three-five page and Visual Studio 2015
that you'll need for building extensions
any version of Visual Studio 2015 is
sufficient any of the Express editions
community on up visual studio comm does
anyone have any more questions before I
get kicked off the stage yes nothing
that I mentioned is going to get back
ported to 2.7 yes ma'am so so the C
compiler once it's installed what
exactly do you mean by good command-line
tools what what we're not installing
bash as part of Visual Studio if that's
what the question is aiming at
definitely once you've installed Visual
Studio at this point you do end up with
a big heavy GUI environment we're
working with the surplus plus team to
try and get an option that will just
give you the compilers without needing
all of the the full environment it's not
a lightweight install at this point
unfortunately and the teams involved are
aware of this and they're working on
alternate distribution so you can just
say I want the C compilers I want to use
them from the command line I don't need
a full editor I don't need C sharp
support
I don't need whatever else comes in the
big massive Visual Studio package and
really trim that down just for people
who need the C compiler so that's coming
I don't have an answer on what exactly
that will look like yet
so it's it's coming sometime in future
Visual Studio 2015 released officially
last week that package is on its own
timescale it's on its own timeline
anything else
yes lots and lots and lots of good
reasons which version would you like to
show up in Windows which version of
Python 33.5 wait every time I ask that
question I get a different response and
those responses have ranged from 2.6 up
to like 3.5
the person who said 2.6 very quickly
understood why we're not going to ship
Python 2.6 with Windows at this point
but the follow-up question the follow-up
question is then what version of Python
do you want to see in Windows in 10
years time because it's very likely it
would be exactly the same version as you
would see next year and is that what you
want to see so until one of the big
problems is resolving the upgradability
issue when we can have either silently
upgrade Python in the background to
newer versions without breaking old code
or whether we do get stuck on a version
is still a big issue that until it's
resolved I am actually working against
shipping Python in Windows I would
rather make it a one-click install for
people to get the version they want but
you need to do the one-click because if
we click it for you we're going to get
it wrong I in five years so 2.7 is
deprecated now we just haven't shut it
down yet
I so so the decision is not actually
between 2 7 & 3 5 there is absolutely
zero chance we would ship to 7 with
Windows I I will happily stand up and
say that without any permission from
upper management off there is zero
percent chance we'll ever ship Python 2
with Windows it would be in the Python 3
line and then the question is minor
version and the follow-up question is
which minor version in 10 years time is
in that version of Windows and it's here
we have good answers for that we can't
even get past that step so we don't like
breaking people's code where we're in
the redhead camp and we don't really
want to be in the same camp as redhead
as far as pythons is concerned right now
yeah sorry
so this is why we're working on making
installation easier for the user to do
rather than making it a core piece of
the operating system I think I am well
past my time now so thank you